Are there fears left that you have not conquered yet?
What are you afraid of?
Oh, wow. Probably singing,...
...singing would be a huge fear in a movie.
Where's my microphone?
No! No, no, I'm not doing that now.
I'm way too afraid.
But you're not scared of anything else?
Yes, I actually am, in real life.
Yes, that's what I mean.
In real life, I'm terrified of porcelain dolls.
I heard that.
Now, did something happen to you when you were a child?
Did a porcelain doll fall on you when you were sleeping?
I don't think so.
There was like a TV show that had like, it was Friday the 13th where there's a possessed porcelain doll,...
...but I just think they're freaky.
I just think they're really super freaky.
They have like, real eyes and they look real.
And I just imagine when I walk by them, their heads turn with you the whole time.